what's going on guys this is Rob we are
back with fall of X and the question you
have all been asking what happened to
the 250
000 mutants that were forced off the
island of krakowa where did they go so
for those of you guys who are just
joining us one of the great things about
this is that this opens up kind of with
a bit of a run over about what's
happened so far which is to say that
basically Humanity has launched its
strike against the mutant population
specifically orcas and that way they
were all just living on the island of
cocoa as their own mutination when
everything went nuts Xavier was forced
to use his telepathy to basically make
everybody leave and so what he's been
doing this entire time is he's literally
just been grieving on the island of
krakowa because he's just the last
person there he can't read the minds of
the people who were sent away from cocoa
they were supposed to go to Mars but if
they were there he'd be able to detect
their existence he can't so he has no
clue where they are we will find out in
this story right we will find out in
this comic but before we do what we end
up doing is switching over to a guy
named Sebastian Shaw and this is
actually kind of wrapping up a bit of a
plot thread for his character now Shaw
is a very often times If we're honest
overlooked character but one of the best
this guy's ability is to basically
absorb any damage that he sustains and
turn it into Power it's cool it's one of
the coolest abilities of anybody in
Marvel Comics but what this guy does is
he basically injects himself with
something that kind of neutralizes or at
least hides his mutant Gene and then he
asked the question of his assistant so
where are my funds at right where's my
money at and what he's told here is your
funds remain unchanged right you have
the same amount of money that you always
did as the guy who ran Shaw Industries
and that's when he starts to freak out
now the question has to be asked why and
what in the world is going on here well
what ends up happening is that in
response to him learning that he doesn't
have any money or at least has the same
money he always did he ends up going to
visit mother righteous now mother
righteous was basically a character
that's been introduced in Marvel Comics
that Marvel has tried over and over
again to make interesting and relevant
and they failed every single time but
she's basically just a chick that's
really good with magic the way this
worked is that Sebastian Shaw had
basically struck a deal with her that
when everything went sideways with
krakowa which it inevitably would that
he would inherit all the riches that
krakowa has to offer the reality here is
that it was a ruse to a degree that he
wasn't paying attention to the words
that she was saying you will inherit all
of Cocoa's riches nothing about that is
word for word you will inherit all of
krakowa's money and that's what he was
wanting to get all the money that
krakowa made based on the selling of all
different kinds of plants and things
like that that could enhance you know
lifespans and cure mental illness and
all that kind of stuff that's what he
cared about so basically he is the owner
of a giant land mass that's literally it
right he owns that Island over there
that seemingly has no real Financial
value whatsoever the other part of this
is that he ends up traveling to the
hellfire club now the reason why this is
important here is because when Sebastian
Shaw was originally introduced in Marvel
Comics during Chris claremont's time
writing the X-Men leading up to like the
Phoenix and dark Phoenix sagas he was
part of the hellfire club and the
hellfire club is basically an
organization that doesn't really want to
control the world per se it wants to
influence the world and it does that
through a combination of bribery or we
here in the United States we don't call
it bribery we call it lobbying but it's
basically using that right it's using
the means the financial means to
basically influence politicians to get
the kind of laws passed that are the
most conducive to them but basically
control everything behind the scenes
once he realizes his membership as the
white King has been revoked on the way
to being forced out he's met by both his
assistant who tells him that Wilson Fisk
has become the new white king which we
for the most part already know about
we'll talk about why that happened here
in a second as well as a telepathic
projection of Emma Frost now the cool
thing about this is that the way that
Emma Frost appears here this is her
original appearance back in the X-Men
comics when she first showed up right
when she was first introduced so it's
cool to see that she has like her
classic look right I absolutely love
this but she literally tells him like
you are a disappointment and where he
asks her like if you're on Earth you're
going to get people killed you know the
rules but you know the new rules mutants
cannot be anywhere on Earth because
Sebastian Shaw is kind of actually
following Rank and file with Humanity
it's one of those things where he sort
of adopted this philosophy that like
it's better to be the devil's right hand
than in his path if that makes any sense
but he's also very much an opportunist
right any chance he's sees to expand his
his influence or power or control he
will absolutely take and this is a
perfect example of that but with Emma
Frost literally calling his bluff she's
just like you did what you did for you
know she says I did what I did for the
children right I'm playing my role for
the kids in order to keep everybody safe
you're doing what you did for money it
was only ever a matter of time before
you lost and you were kicked out you are
working against us you are not on our
side and so it's one of those things
where not only does he have no place
within the hellfire club he has no place
with the mutants that actually reside on
Earth he's a man with no home and it's
only a matter of time before orcas or
any of the organizations that are out
there that are targeting mutants come to
the realization that he is a mutant and
that his days are numbered right like
it's only a matter of time before that
happens so what he does is he comes to
this decision and he says okay fine if
all I own is just a giant land mass out
there that's okay I don't need the money
of krakowa right my power is to turn
sense into bill billions so what I'll do
is I'll pillage the place all the while
completely unaware of the fact that
Charles Xavier is still there this is
amazing it's one of these moments when
you see Charles Xavier just like use the
full totality of his telepathy and just
like like a violent way because while
he's there just kind of mourning
everything he's met by Emma Frost who
contacts him telepathically and says
look you mourn as long as you want to
but understand the time is going to come
when you're going to have to actually
step into this conflict you're gonna
have to step in and you're gonna have to
do something for right now I'm reaching
out to t'challa Reed Richards anybody
that I believe can help us now this is
one of those moments where it just kind
of looks like Charles Xavier is moping
and to a degree it's true but one of the
things to know is that in Marvel very
rarely do you ever see Charles Xavier
lose it when it comes to his telepathy
this whole story is inevitably leading
to like a massive battle and when it
does I would not be surprised if you see
Charles Xavier blow the doors off of
everything we've known about his ability
to use telepathy his ability to use his
powers and what he's capable of we get a
little bit of a of a dose of it when
Sebastian Shaw's forces roll up on the
beaches with the intention of just kind
of casually making their way through and
so on and so forth and Xavier just kind
of like manifests right these gigantic
monsters and different things like that
it's a very small thing but imagine
someone like Xavier doing this on a
planetary level right imagine for
example that like some massive conflict
happens and Xavier uses his telepathy to
trick every human in the world into
believing that like aliens are invading
from like another planet right except in
this instance the people they see as
aliens are actually orcas and like
literally Humanity starts wiping out
orcas without realizing what they're
doing right it's one of the things
Xavier doesn't really do because he
doesn't believe in using his powers for
nefarious purposes but when you are a
telepath on that level your ability to
influence and to control the world
that's Child's Play and so him
potentially using his powers to
influence Humanity as a small thing
because what he says here is in the
midst of all this he says I tried to let
go but in the end I couldn't they forced
my hand yes but I still didn't and now
my people are dead it's too late to let
go now I will hold on to this rock as it
sinks but as long as I live I will not
let their memory be desecrated by those
who are bathed in blood I would rather
the Air was torn from their lungs than
they smell the flowers growing on this
mutant grave no more no more no more
those are the words of a man who's about
to wage war like a one-man war against
the entirety of the human population now
getting to the thing that you all came
here for where in the world are all the
other mutants what we end up doing is
transitioning to a play place that's
only described as nowhere and know when
we can largely assume this is a place
between Dimensions it's not Otherworld
right so it's not like some other
dimension that we're already familiar
with they're seemingly just kind of out
there in the middle of nowhere with no
real indication of where they are they
can't be detected by Xavier so they're
not on Earth and so what ends up
happening is we basically pick up with
Hope Summers as well as Exodus now
Exodus I've said it before I'll say it
again it Bears repeating and you can
never get tired of doing it this guy's
one of the most powerful mutants to ever
exist in the history of Marvel Comics
shy of being able to alter reality on a
universal scale there's nothing this guy
can do his telepathy and telekinesis
make him just astronomically powerful
Destiny is here as well but while
Destiny is a precognitive and she can
see the future while she's here she
can't see anything she cannot see what's
to come down the road for anyone and so
what ends up happening is that as Exodus
makes us way right kind of coming to he
says there are 250 000 mines here none
of them are Mystique or the rest of the
five for that matter the five basically
being the mutants that are capable of
resurrecting other mutants from the dead
so once they die there's no conceivable
way to bring them back he says it's the
whole population of krakowa the ones
Xavier forced to walk through the portal
they were meant to arrive on a Rocco I.E
Mars instead we came here to the desert
and it's one of those things where it's
like we have no food we have no water
right some of us are still wearing our
formal outfits like what in the world
are we going to do and exodus gets this
um there's like this amazing moment
right and it's so cool because if you
know the history of Exodus this ties in
perfectly with it and I'll talk about
what that means here in a second but he
says listen to me mutants we will
survive the desert as I did so long ago
we will be transformed like I was we are
mutant pilgrims I will lead you to the
promised land trust me I have seen this
in a vision long long ago we are the
people of krakowa we only have each
other we have only ever had each other
and whether we live or die we will live
and die together this way follow me now
one of the things to know about this
right one of the things to understand
Exodus is a guy called Bennett do Paris
right or or Paris whatever you want to
call him the port behind this is he was
part of the Crusades right he was a guy
whose telepathy and telekinesis was
unlocked by apocalypse right but this
guy had like traversed the desert
looking for a quote-unquote person that
could give him his Destiny he was
ultimately locked away for a lengthy
amount of time and then once he escaped
he started off as a villain and then
ultimately became a hero but this guy
understands what it means to be this
almost kind of Moses type character
right guiding his people through the
desert to what's basically salvation but
he's also a born leader and
astronomically powerful and so what he
realizes here is that some of these
mutants who were on this journey will
presumably die right some of them just
simply will not survive the elements for
any number of reasons they will band
together and they will try to keep each
other safe but under the current Exodus
starts to realize the fear they have
will turn to anger and that anger can be
channeled they can be turned into an
army 250
000 strong and so when he's asked the
question by hope what is this way Exodus
his response is a promised land and when
she asked do you truly know this his
response is absolutely not but I have
faith this guy is literally taking these
people to a destination that seemingly
doesn't exist along the way they will be
turned into an army and when the time
comes this Army will have its revenge
and it will come Swift and it will come
hard and it will come in the form of a
Reckoning with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you need to get caught up on fall of X
make sure you guys click this link to
the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace